[Musique]
combinés 3g vous qu'il y ait deux papas
peluche tue le foot robeco notez bien
sur vos droits et moi d'abord parce que
attention il vous manque
[Musique]
grâce lui la plus belle et savent que
moi
d'autres folies à la fois parce que
j'aimerais moi que mam baldar d'eau à
balbala bla bla bla bla rival abdullah
lors du synode je voudrais un peu de
silence
qu'est ce que tu dis pas par coeur j
migraine épouvantable
est ce que tu pourrais arrêter de
chanter but à furnes mais pourquoi le
moindre petit bris me fait terriblement
souffrir
d'accord d'accord va mater
[Musique]
pourquoi ne fait plus de bruit j'ai très
mal à la tête
ça tombe mal strassen machin faveur
music machine à bruit c'est ça et sa
pâte à tarte
bien vite oulala elle est vraiment
malade me mets pas je m'en vais au
nombre est on sera en mesure
je jure sur mon marteau
j'ai vu aussi un de mes fourneaux jr un
charlot 1 sur la base d'un vitesse
[Musique]
je vais mieux
et ce silence commence à me peser à papa
papa j'ai alors pas ta cloud et cette
machine puisque personne ne veut plus me
parler je vais faire du bruit
monsieur bougon descendra et je pourrais
parler avec lui comme ça vous me fait
plus de bruit à l'athlète mois
hop
[Musique]
[Rires]
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de pâte
à pêcher le faux trompez pas compter
bien sûr photo
le témoin n'a pas grand clown attention
il me manque un
[Musique]